tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fa vj e dolci siamo solo allora
allora vi spiego una roba avete presente
il gioco fai un night e file porca merda
non sono anche di nice nice ed anime
hanno fatto file mezza età di me 2
lo faccio partire entra guy o direi che
possiamo cominciare la cosa che ancora
non ho capito è perchè continuano a fare
i sequel di questo videogame security ni
da allora il primo videogame di fi match
in anime carolo fatto era bello notte
uno senza notte ragazzi allora per chi
non lo conoscesse ragazzi sarebbe tipo
una parodia insomma perché ci sono degli
slip se una parodia di fi nights
freddy's che quel gioco bello che mi
piace tanto invece di freddy ci sono
stati pe con le tette e lo scopo del
gioco è quello di sopravvivere fino alle
6 del mattino prima che miste temi mi
uccida poi non è che mi uccide mysore ex
asia io non so se questo gioco un
subliminale tutto subliminale suo ma
quelli mi sembrano di eni po calati ma
nel condotto mi sta per uscire come si
esce parola sono uscito dal gioco
proprio no in quel senso come si esce
come si esce dalle condotte al maghazi
affatto una minchiata di quelle assurde
4 ci sono le regole scritte primo regola
rispettare gli animatronics che
sarebbero letizie credo seconda regola
tenere il posto pulito terza regola non
toccare le tecniche cose te le il petto
di freddy quarta regola love dragon ball
che mi sembra più seria di pete quarto e
giustamente ragazzi l'importante è
tratto sta tizia già qua c'è com'è
possibile
come fai a essere sia lì che qui hanno
nella stessa non toccare a meno che non
sia personale autorizzato sì perché
personale autorizzato po palpare gli
anima trani giustamente dov'è la tipa
ecco perfetta tette sullo schermo
ragazzi non potevo immaginarmi in modo
migliore per morire con quelli sono dei
pegni
ditemi quello che volete ma sono pene è
la cosa che vorrei capire ancora pikachu
allora come sono perché ok sono riuscito
a morire the popular fra di anime
convention un recente omicidio ma cosa
che invece mi ha messo le dette in
faccia
in questo gioco ragazzi se una persona
team e che le tette in faccia
muori non lo so perché non so per quale
motivo stratford crepi si mettono le dat
in faccia quando mi attaccano che mi
mettono le tette e io non voglio che mi
tocchino con le tette come facciamo
andare via se io non voglio le tette
come faccio c'è un mondo seriamente c'è
una tizia c'è una pizza nella nella
stanza dei giochi cala mignot ai box
stai muove qualcuno viene a mostrare
alle pappe sempre dall'azzurra allora io
io io adesso si chiude sta roba ok io
per difendermi devo mettermi gli slip
perché quindi se la tipa arriva io
mostro gli slip e la tipa se ne va a
giusto giusto giusto ovvio come ho fatto
a non capire che dovevo mostrare gli
slip che questo o cazzo giudica chiodi
ok o gli slip addosso sono io se cito
uno a sucate ne devi annà cioè fatti di
essere pignocca di mezzi hanno hai
capito un cazzo da lì si sono strappati
gli slip fantastico
c'è una telecamera rai che può non è che
può far veder la facciano proprio le
tette
ce l'avevo di corpo c'è un desktop che
no anzi non scherzavano ne detiene un
culo abela del sig
stai scontati ai livelli si slip da uomo
virile ecco perfetto sono accorto quando
si accorgono gli slip ragazzi non c'è
verso sono finite se volete vedermi più
spesso costi slip ditelo prima
dov'è la tipa solo le due di notte
ragazzi quindi pian piano già sto
facendo problema che non vedo pilati pad
i primi ragazzi non c'è verso la tipa
blu era è ossessionato da me perché ci
avevo gli slip
si sa che alle donne piace l'uomo con
gli slip d'accordo raccordo fermi tutti
allora ascoltate un secondo il gioco non
va avanti nel senso che muoio sempre
io sempre così quindi il gioco si ferma
così quindi ragazzi ho dovuto farlo
anche se è durato poco scusatemi però
dovevo farlo
ok adesso che siccome se non posso
concludere qui il video se non sarebbe
troppo corto passiamo ad un altro loro
un po più serio magari visto che l'ho
scaricato adesso che i ragazzi e la en
rose stairway fantastico stato non
fatemi domande del perché sul desktop
show roba tipo questa fate finta di non
averla vista giochiamolo raga non ho
neanche lo avrò così proprio lo apro
adesso io ho fatto vedere poco di fare
niente un lavoro ma il gioco è veramente
dura poco però no secondo un po troppo
corto il video facciamo anche questo a
esistono i menu nei giochi fateli
potrebbe anche essere un gioco di cucina
se non mi dite che cazzo sto giocando
siamo ragazzi su è la e non stairway che
è un gioco di bd di scale ciao zio
quanto sieber lo ha trovato posto sul
mare
hai una tizia ciao zia assomiglia un po
mia nonna si insomma con gli occhi
fantastico è una salve lei c'è poco da
mandare a [ __ ] perché non mi conosci
neanche i [ __ ] e anzi forse è meglio
così
tra l'altro è un bello della giornata
una nonna mi sa che c'è un tornado fuori
certo tesoro mai mangiato a pranzo è
pieno zeppo di birra e non si sa perché
neanche sul cornicione nonna ct 6 data
alla gargarozzo stamattina io scendo è
in scendo giù attenta al cascata la
lattina gradi grazie non ho mai lanciato
l'attività fasce lugas da nonna che
lancia le lattine vale io poi entrò
bello tra l'altro il caso è uno ti sei
fatto che le sedi perché sto sentendo un
muro che piange prego enti pure anzi la
pro io la pressione si preoccupi faccio
io faccio ma basta spingere non è
difficile
vedo qualcosa ma non vada è meglio il
nono scoprirlo
se riesce ad entrare ti offro della
birra alla la jolie è nonna non hai mai
pagato la bolletta dell'enel non fai la
guardia c'è qualcosa di strano insaccato
da che non va bene
devo ancora capire il problema come mai
lampeggia al lampadario a caso l'altro
ancora non ho capito
porca la [ __ ] salve signor a un
giorno bella giornata è senza il es
guardi la sua usare la maniglia la
maniglia quella si usa e la apre la
porta e vai su ciò può fare a me da lei
che piangevano il muro a discussi guarda
le plus offrire una birra per questa
questo mio errore guarda le offre questa
18 gradi
accompagnata viene un bel tavernello non
le piace la birra fa schifo
grazie della luce cazzo andata però
posso entrare si graffi e lei non era
difficile basta usare la maniglia
la donna d'oggi la pigrizia manco la
maniglia altro un gioco come una grafica
fantastica se non fosse per chi cazzo è
successo non hai ivy hai visto il tuo
anche tu che sono entrato di cui
successo vuoi corno cup sono caduto non
so dove salve salutarla la porta molto
brava mi scusi non hanno no ascolti la
birra l'abi e brendola vi raffo cazzola
birra e per me per lei l'ho lasciata per
lei e porca [ __ ]
grazie nota si apre non ci credo no non
è possibile
dai non è vero salve
bella il mangiato del pesto vai dal
dentista tesoro per cortesia
bella la mia eleonora molto bello
e finito così sul serio renato aruffo in
arte renato zero ha fatto questo gioco
renato zero ecco perché fantastico e mi
è piaciuto troppissimo fall renato fi
visitare
eleonora da un dentista perché comunque
special guest mia nonna nel gioco mi è
piaciuto molto
i due consigli 1 metti il menu e 2
cambia la musica dei dei titoli di coda
che non è proprio bach
ma sti gran cazzo ma [ __ ] vedi
ragazzi spero che vita vi sia piaciuto
qualcuno mio episodio dovuto dire due
video perché è uno era troppo corto
l'altro ancora più corto quindi spero
che vi sia piaciuto spero che abbiate
imparato tutti quanti che le maniglie
vanno tirate e poi si entra nelle porte
se vedete la stessa stanza di prima è
perché vi siete fatti delle canne però
capito vi sia piaciuto a casa se vi è
piaciuta stato argomento è un mi piace
anche a passioni facebook e con i vita
tra dando inizio a una serie di scatti
ci vediamo prossimo vito dei ragazzi